or something
[Music]
you boasted openly of having six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
I'm not taking him there's no moral view
from me
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
one of the most infamous men in the
world Andrew Tate's misogynistic tirade
have been viewed billions of Times
online he's now been effectively banned
though from the internet he doesn't
think that's fair tonight I'm gonna try
and work out if it is
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
and welcome to special edition of Piers
Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one on one
he's the most famous man you probably
never heard of with billions of views
online at one point this year more
people were searching Google for Andrew
Tate and Donald Trump or Kim Kardashian
former professional kickboxer he was
kicked off big brother in 2016 after a
video emerged of him striking a woman
and what they now both claimed was the
consensual sex game he since made
Millions as a pornographer casino owner
in Romania but it's his online videos
that have made him notorious across the
world posing as a Playboy with fast cars
cigars weapons and cash
he rants about his often scandalous
views on women or instruct a female to
provide sustenance
cool so I think my sister is my her
husband's property yes until young men
they can get as rich as him by paying
for his digital life lessons
I have a hundred business tips I'm going
to teach you which will allow you to
make your own money instantly
maybe a backlash the net has clothes
around who takes while Millions still
share his videos it's effectively banned
from the web booted off Facebook YouTube
Instagram Twitter and Tick Tock to his
fans is a misunderstood satirist and the
victim of big Tech censorship to many
others he's a malicious misogynist
tonight I'll try and get to the truth
well some of the opinions Andrew Tate
shares in his videos are undeniably
deeply offensive we're going to show you
some of them on this show I think you
should see them yourself not simply hear
what he says about them or what other
people say about them tens of millions
of people across the world follow Andrew
Tate and when the big Following comes a
big responsibility as well as a public
interest in holding his views to account
if outrageous opinions are read aloud
they can be challenged and exposed for
what they are they're silenced the
person holding these views can become a
martyr so that's why I invited Andrew
Tate to come here tonight and he joins
me now live so Andrew well welcome first
of all
um you come all the way from Romania to
do this interview correct what do you
hope to achieve from this interview why
are you here it'd be interesting to have
a conversation with you you've certainly
been uh the subject of your own divided
opinions in the world there's a lot of
people who would say some of the things
you say are perhaps dangerous or toxic
so I thought you'd be a good person to
speak to about this subject I didn't
know much about you before this year and
then I suddenly became very aware of you
as the world did because was as I said
earlier you you were the number one
subject searched on Google ahead of
Donald Trump I don't think it was even
possible why did you get suddenly so
popular stroke Infamous do you think I
exploded uh I certainly didn't do that
with magic I've been on the internet for
a very long time I think in the world we
live in now as the other side the other
side the people who disagree with me as
they get more and more tyrannical in
their censorships and their hate mobs
Etc as standard masculine practices are
deemed toxic I didn't put a magic spell
on everybody I managed to accumulate a
large amount of affinity with the male
populace Across the Western world
because I'm simply saying things that
many men believe think and feel the
problem I would say is I want to play
you just a clip off the top this is from
Joe Rogan he's somebody I absolutely
love sure and I think it explains to me
what my what I presume my issue with you
is going to be right correct and you you
have absolutely got the right to try and
persuade me otherwise sure but Joe Rogan
said this about you
my 12 year old and my 14 year old asked
me about Andrew Tate
I said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer I like him a lot why do you
like him and I was asking they said he
says a lot of funny stuff on on Twitter
and Tick Tock he [ __ ] up with the
misogynist yes because if he didn't do
that if he just said the pro mail stuff
so I thought that was interesting
because when I've gone over everything
that's been at the center of the debate
about Andrew Tate I come down with Joe
Rogan in the sense that there's a lot of
stuff you say I agree with you know I've
got three sons in their 20s it's not
easy actually being a young male in the
modern world
um and I think a lot of the things that
you say about that uh can resonate with
them the problem comes with the I don't
know 10 20 or whatever of your output
which on the face of it appears to be
blatant misogyny and when you couple
that with your massive influence and
huge reach that is why the social media
companies have decided to effectively
cancel you I don't believe in
cancellation I don't believe in
censorship particularly that's why I've
invited you to come on the show
um but I do think a lot of the things
you've said are blatant misogyny do you
accept that so you made a very
interesting point there you just said on
the face of it appear to be blatantly
misogynistic I understand that on the
face of some of the long format content
I've made if you're going to take a few
seconds of hours chop it up put it all
over social media accompany with my
massive Fame then things can absolutely
be taken out of context I do not hate
women in any regard I have no negative
relationship with women no women have
come forward saying I've hurt them I've
no criminal record for hurting women
there's no way I can be seen as the face
or the devil in regards to how men treat
women on on the planet I'm absolutely
not really the opposite I believe in
protecting and providing I've been
misunderstood there's been large
contingents of people who have tried
very hard to purport lies about me and
and the the truth of the matter is I've
been producing content for a very long
time hours and hours of videos been cut
down to two or three seconds of clip
those clips have gone viral and people
misunderstand me I think you you use
this phrase and be taken out of context
and I'm not I'm not sure that is correct
in the sense that it still comes out of
your mouth and some of the things
completely some of the things you've
said I just think are blatantly well
let's do let's do them well let's hear
them let's go through something sure
right so you said this about me too
stroke rape this is probably 40 of the
reason I moved to Romania in Eastern
Europe none of this garbage flies you go
to the police and say he raped me back
in 1988 they'll say well you should have
done something about it back then yeah
so the point I was making was obviously
at the height of the metoo Scandal and
also if we look at Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp there's been a lot of high
profile cases where men have been
accused of things they did not do
without evidence and their lives have
been completely and utterly destroyed
when I say these things people sit and
say that oh he hates women I don't hate
women I think rapist disgusting I would
take a stronger stance on rape than the
British government I think these people
should face a death penalty but to sit
and say that women without evidence can
go forward and just make up accusations
against men even though they've been
repeatedly proven to destroy men's lives
at will is absolutely what about a woman
who was raped back in 1988 and goes to
the police then then the man should face
absolutely complete justice
but you understand that when that clip
appears on tick tock as a clip and all
right that's a clip completely okay but
it's still something came out of your
mouth do you accept that when that
appears on Tick Tock a lot of young
maybe not as smart as you young men
right impressionable teenagers we'll
read that and go what's he saying is he
saying that rape doesn't exist no I
completely I'm not going to sit here as
a professional and say that I can't be
taken out of context what I will say is
that one small sentence you've taken was
from a one hour video where I explained
that of course rape is disgusting of
course everybody should be punished for
the crimes regardless of when they
happen but people are not perfect male
and female and if you give women the
opportunity to destroy men's lives
without evidence there's going to be a
contingent of women who will do that do
you think do you think women are the
property of men no the point why have
you said they are because I made a
religious point I said that when a man
marries a woman the woman's father walks
him down the aisle walks her down the
aisle and hands her away to the man
traditionally that's what it says in the
Bible I'm a religious person I believe
in God I live in the Muslim so you do
think that the woman becomes the men I
think she takes his last name I mean
let's watch the clip that you said about
sure so that we can get it in context
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but I've been married
twice as it turns out and on both
occasions I didn't believe that the
woman was being handed to me as chattel
as property and perhaps the way that
that the reason I'm asked that question
repeatedly and I'm asked in a loaded way
so would you rephrase what you said
there now what that's that's an
interesting point about phrasing the way
I would say things before I was famous I
have to take personal responsibility and
accept right that if I make a video
about 500 people see and one percent of
them misunderstand it that's not a
problem if I make a video that 5 million
people see and one percent of them under
so specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's problem she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has seen
it herself right so she she's still a
sovereign individual she's absolutely
property means that the husband owns
your sister listen my friend if you want
to argue about this you need to go back
to the Bible to the Quran you need to
argue with religious talk about anything
in the Bible of Quran that's what it
says no no I'm asking you what you think
I think that if a woman marries a man
and she decides to take his last name
that they have different roles and
responsibilities within that marriage
and I believe that that's not the
question she's had I believe the father
I am the father don't behave like a
politician the father hands her to the
man Robert don't be a politician because
I think you're a straight talker right
you keep telling me you're straight talk
I think my sister is her husband's
property do you regret saying it like
that I I understand that with my
newfound Fame perhaps it could be
phrased differently however I still
believe that a woman is given to the man
in marriage that's what I believe yeah
but not as property now the property is
the word that other people use the
question but as a an equal partner in a
loving Union that's what marriage
actually means it doesn't mean that when
you get married the woman is given to
you as a bit of Chapel agreed so why say
it but that's the way that people ask me
the question people say to me they asked
the question you can't blame people for
asking you questions surely if you want
to be accountable for what you said
you've got to own your responses don't
blame the question I own the response
let me ask you a question now and you
say something and then say well actually
I blame me for I understand pears peers
I understand I believe the woman is
given to the man I believe she's given
away by the father I believe she belongs
to the man so she belongs to them
fundamentally right so fundamentally you
do believe that a woman becomes a man's
property I believe she belongs to the
man in marriage correct right
I see that to me is misogyny and you're
entitled to your opinion right but do
you want did you not understand why
people think it is misogyny I understand
why some people can be very offended by
what I say what they do is they take a
point like that and they ignore all the
other points I make the other way right
that's why that's why I've repeatedly
asked you about that line to see if
you've changed your position but the
reality is you haven't it's not about
changing positions I'm a full-grown
adult and I stick by the things I say
and I'm responsible for them which by
the way is fine absolutely so what you
did say at the start of this little
exchange you said you know I wouldn't
maybe say things the same way now that I
did before I was famous and yet actually
you've doubled on certain points so that
is what you believe that's my point yes
I'm trying to work out look I don't know
you we just met right yeah I'm trying to
work out who Andrew Tate is and what you
actually believe I don't want to twist
anything at all then maybe make it very
very clear to the camera I believe a
woman is given to the man in marriage
but a man doesn't own a woman it's not
no it's honestly literally buy them as a
slave well obviously we're not talking
about that we're talking about religious
biblical marriage we're talking about
something else yeah but I'm a Christian
I don't believe that I I I I own my wife
do you believe your wife was given away
to you when she took her last name I
believe that there is a process where a
father traditionally walks his daughter
down the aisle and hands his daughter to
this man and they stand there and become
a union of two loving people in a
partnership no because there's no
ownership involved you're a smart guy
right there's no denying that you're a
smart you're a good talker I've seen a
lot of the stuff but when you what what
I don't think you quite fully understand
now I understand when young
impressionable people I understand you
are not as smart see things like I think
my sister is a husband's property yes
and you've just reaffirmed that that
belief they think that they have the
right to own women I understand that
very well Pierce which that's why people
think you're a massage completely I
understand all of this very well which
is why when you're saying I was
backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret though over the way you phrase
this stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds can be taken out of
context you went on to say about
authority over women if I have a
responsibility over I must have a degree
of authority yeah for the same reason if
I have responsibility over and people
are going to lose their mind it's an
example an energy responsibility over a
child I have to have some Authority so
you believe as part of your ownership or
your property of of the woman you have
authority over her no I believe if you
ever that's what you said I believe
you've ever responsibility over
something you have to have a degree of
authority you can't be responsible but
Authority means again that you're the
boss the point I'm making if you'll
please let me finish at this point the
point I was trying to make was talking
about the safety of a woman she was
walking alone at night and I was saying
well I wouldn't let my woman walk alone
at night and they said well you're not
in charge of her you don't get to decide
what she does I say I understand but if
I'm responsible for her safety and I'm
the person who's burdened with making
sure she is safe I have to have the
authority to say don't put yourself in
unsafe situations the two things are
linked well you know you don't have
authority you have the you can
absolutely have the right to say to the
woman you're with I don't think you
should but ultimately if she decides
then I can't force her right so
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies I have
the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible that's not what
Authority means I I accept that you use
the analogy of responsibility for a
child my friend these are these are very
these are actually really important
things they're important things but you
introduce you introduce you interrupt me
every five seconds so it's hard for me
to actually explain my point the point
I'm making here is very simple you have
children and you're responsible for
their safety so you're going to have
authority to say don't go out at night
perhaps because you want them to be safe
you have legal Authority you have a
legal Authority yeah legal Authority I'm
saying that if I had a woman and the
question where you've raised a sound
bite from I was asked about protecting a
woman making sure she's safe and I would
say I wouldn't want her to go out at
night on her own because I'm responsible
for her safety and someone said well you
don't have authority over to do that and
I said well no I can't force her to stay
inside but if she were to ask me how do
I protect myself at night I would say
well you should stay inside that's how
you should do that's I don't have an
issue with so we agree no it's the
semantics it's not semantics and this is
what I don't think you quite get why
there's a fury over what you say with
respect because the semantics point
would be we're saying the same thing in
different ways but we're not I'm saying
to you know what do you say I have to
have some authority over a woman I say
to you you have no right to any
authority over a woman you do over a
child a visual child because you are the
legal appointed guardian of that child
you're not illegally appointed guardian
or authority over your wife or female
legally appointed absolutely not I agree
however
when it comes to things like personal
response or personal safety men largely
by Society are accepted we're the
protectors and providers we can sit here
and pretend that in the world we live in
if me and my wife were walking down the
street and men were to come up and try
and attack us I wouldn't be the one
fighting but we both know in reality I
would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
survive a degree of responsibility to
protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never put herself you
wish you hadn't used the word Authority
The Authority is something that she
would give to me she would come to me
and say how do how can I make sure
I don't interrupt you I just want to
point out that's not what Authority
means if someone gives you can a person
can get voluntary Authority is not
authoritative no but that's the point
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety
coming up more from Andrew Tate
join me Ian Collins every day on talk TV
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers Alan in Grimsby
Tracy in Burton on Trent Dave thank you
very much picking apart the
this simply does not wash look who's
back under the spotlight
to those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
you're the most honest man in the world
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead no go
ahead go ahead my question is this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had
of being president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question I don't only believe
that I know it will happen
we will win you can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
but don't say that in public here
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as
I've said before it's the best thing to
tell people yes because when you're fed
up with them you go up you know you can
say it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
I'm not gonna watch what I say sorry
because I don't think you do either
really I think that both of us I think
have the self-confidence to say you know
what stuff this nonsense uh yeah stuff
the fun police is saying well my great
friend used to say uh because I think
it's just so what it does it removes all
the fun out of life it makes life a very
joyless kind of experience doesn't it I
don't know what's going on in the world
everybody's upset for something and no
matter what you say can please everybody
but for me the only person I'm
interested in pleasing a new wife and
I'm struggling with that most of the
time
I I can't play like that my wife gets
mad my wife
well your wife is always thinking I'm
going to get canceled or something
[Music]
you boasted openly of adding six seven
Partners at once so is that
righteousness there's no moral view from
me
[Music]
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one
on one
do you respect women absolutely why
wouldn't I do you think the 18 19 year
old woman are more attractive than 25
year old woman I think there's
Attractive people uh that's that's a
loaded question I don't know it's not
real is it I I can't know why I'm asking
you of course I do but I can't sit here
and so the benefit of you is you don't
know why I'm asking you said this in
general this is also one of the reasons
men find youth attractive you want to
blow up the internet or block the
internet write effing now the reason 18
and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less dick people say oh you
can't say that but yes I can a 19 year
old is more attractive than 26 year old
woman and I'll tell you why because that
26 year old has talked to more guys been
to the club more times being effed and
dumped more times more arguments more
mass more for me to clean up that is
misogyny why because you are encouraging
a mindset about 25 year old women that
makes them sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case that
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
will be more desired pretty anti-25 year
old woman Auntie 25 year old woman we
can argue but not misogynistic well
that's massage that's no no no it's not
being anti any woman at all is misogyny
not when I'm not what I'm saying that
women are beautiful and attractive at a
certain age and saying the ages you're
saying 18 19 years are more attractive
than 21 other than ageist perhaps but
misogynistic absolutely but you just
accepted it was misogyny no I didn't you
said it was more Sergeant I'm telling
you no it's not so you don't think if
you're saying slightly hateful things
about it that's not slightly hateful
well it is you think you you say that to
a woman's face if she's 25 it's not
slightly hateful when you would go up to
25 year old woman and tell her exactly
what I've just read why would I walk up
to a random 25 because you said it in
public it's on the internet and it's
been listened to and watched by millions
and millions of young Impressions
correct there was a large panel there
was a conversation whereas hours Longs
of conversation there were feminists
attacking men for toxic masculine and
attacking me and saying things and I
said things back which we're going to
enter but I think see I'm I so which
you've done yourself a bunch of times I
think a lot of allegations of toxic
masculinity are not toxic correct I do
think that kind of uh sentence I just
read out that that paragraph is actually
toxic if you genuinely mean that and you
say you wouldn't say it to a woman's
face but you said it in public about
women of that age I do think that's
misogynist and I think you probably do
too I don't think it's misogynistic I
understand why it can be insulting to
you wouldn't say it to a woman's face
well it depends you're making out like
I'm walking around the street going up
to randomly you're doing it to tens of
millions of people online there's no
difference not at all we're discussing a
topic we're discussing the the ideal age
of a man should should young boys right
in their teens are you comfortable that
they would have that mindset be honest I
think that young boys in their teens
lack life experience they lack nuance
and they need to be very very careful
what they're digesting online whether
it's my content or anybody else's we
agree about other things but when I read
that kind of thing I'm like
I just how much of that is you how much
of that is some ACT do you regret saying
stuff like this I don't actually do you
see it as weakness to admit you
shouldn't have said something like that
no I don't live with regret I think
what's happened is that like I said long
format content arguments with feminists
arguments with the toxic masculine crowd
arguments with the left and they're
going to take a small clip small
sentence from hours and they're going to
try and paint me but I'm not left or
right I don't know what you are Pierce
exactly that's my point that's my point
and I understand and and you're doing
exactly as I knew would happen on this
interview which is because you're a busy
man you're not gonna watch hours and
hours and hours of video actually I
haven't watched thousand hours of video
and I'm going to come to the stuff where
I agree with you and I'm going to come
to the stuff about your censorship which
I have issues with so this is It's a
Long interview right sure I just thought
off the top you said to me and you were
quite bold about it well go on then
let's go through this and you and you
should keep going I will sit here and
stand by what I said I believe that oh
man on that I just read to you that yeah
do you wish you hadn't said that
I understand how it's been misconstrued
I understand how it's been weaponized
against me do I regret it because it's
been weaponized and used against me well
that's slightly annoying did I that's
not why did I at the time mean what I
said and in the context of the
conversation which obviously you you're
not familiar with and the people at home
are not familiar with no I meant what I
said the 25 year old women have just
talked to more guys been to the club
more times being effed and dumped more
times more arguments More Mess more for
me to clean up well there's a whole much
there's a whole bunch of context and
conversation around that that's been
missed and I don't think I'm missing
much context well I I encourage people
who are interested to go watch it right
but I mean I've just read out three
sentences on the bounce there I don't
think there's any context I'm missing I
mean you'll you've made it pretty clear
what you think about the difference
between 18 and 90 year old women I
wasn't talking about myself even I was
explaining I was talking with a Muslim
guy who was on the panel and he was
explaining how youth is very valid
valued in most parts of the world and
why Virginia is valued in both parts of
the world the feminists were arguing
against it the conversation has been
misunderstood they've taken this clip of
it and it's been weaponized and used
against me I understand that is because
I'm now the most famous Google person on
the planet it's inconvenient sure but
I'm definitely not a danger to women in
any regard I date women 25 26 27 years
old all the time none of them are
offended by the thing I don't think
you're a danger to women I think that I
think the danger if it concerns you the
danger is the influence you have on
young men to have this kind of mindset
about women and that's really what I'm
trying to get to what you really believe
and how much you've just shot off
because you think it's like entertaining
and you haven't really given it much
thought and whether now you're a bit
older and you've had all the Fallout
where the part of you is thinking
actually if I had as Joe Rogan says if
you hadn't said stuff like this you'd
probably still be on these platforms
you'd be massively more popular
massively more famous massively richer
so I'm really just trying to get to on
the blatantly misogynist stuff do you
just wish you hadn't said it with great
power comes great responsibility it was
certainly said before the great power
came it's inconvenient to a degree
however like I said at the time with the
context of the conversation I know that
I'm not saying things which I believe to
be detrimental to the world however
they've been misconstrued and they've
been misunderstood if a 25 year old
woman was watching this would you say
I'm sorry for saying that oh I wouldn't
want anyone to be offended by anything I
say but I say things but I say things
that offend and this is the thing that's
interesting Pierce please let me finish
are you again like a politician but hang
on you could say I'm interrupting you do
but you're answering a different
question to the one I asked you so as an
interviewer you're sure okay sure okay
you accept that let's accept we both got
up okay so again my point is simply if a
26 year old woman is watching this and
has heard those comments would you just
say to her look I'm sorry I shouldn't
have said that no I won't I will say
that I am sorry that that offends you
however there's a large contingent of
the world it doesn't mean you're sorry
no I'm not sorry that's the point I'm
making I'm sorry if that offends you
however there's a large contingent of
the world that believed that and I was
mediating for a conversation parts of
the world that believed that about 26
year old women are parts of the world
where women are not allowed out on their
own that's your that's a conversation
you have to wear full burkas well that's
a conversation you're not allowed to
drive cars that's nothing to do with it
but is that the kind of world for a
woman I was mediating I was mediating a
conversation I'm asking you what you
think I I don't live in a country where
that happens you're using that as the
excuse for why you're not sorry for
saying it it's not is that there are
parts of the world but this is fine my
question to you is well do you think
it's fine I don't think it's fine I live
in a world where you don't think it's
fine my the reason this isn't that hard
Andrew you can simply say beers you know
what with the benefit of hindsight I
wish I hadn't said it like that and if a
26 year old woman's watching I'm sorry I
said that because that actually is
blatantly misogynist and even though
that's the view held by other parts of
the world it's not a view I share now I
would respect you more if you said that
yeah than if you try and say Well it
said in other parts of the world so I'm
not sorry I think that doesn't tell me
what you think then you need to
understand why my content existed in the
first place my content existed because I
tried my very hardest to be an absolute
not a realist especially with
uncomfortable truths I was pointing out
that very uncomfortable is that a truth
it's an uncomfortable truth in many
parts of the world it's not a proof that
I'm happy about it's not true no hang on
you're doing it again
what do you mean that's the truth in
other parts of the world that's what you
said it's not you're not talking about
another part of the world you're talking
about what you believe is the difference
between 18 and 90 year olds and 26 year
olds I was talking about your belief I
was talking about what the people on the
panel believe the difference is
so what do you think the difference is I
think the difference is age what's the
difference though well then 26 year olds
older than the 19 year old and so you
stand by what you said about talking to
the guys been to the club more times
been after dump more times you believe
that or not no there's plenty of 26 year
old women who have been with one man or
a virgin of course so you don't believe
that I don't think that the age is the
only thing that's going to decipher well
how many men or women so if you don't
actually believe what you said just say
sorry it's not I've not believe in what
I'm saying it's about you understanding
that there's large conversations going
on you were saying what you think
is is I I feel like you're trying to pin
me down if it's not what you believe
just say I don't believe that
what part wouldn't I believe well you
tell me which part you don't believe
there's the sentence which part would
you now say you don't believe
I believe that 25 year old women perhaps
have had because they've been alive
longer maybe have had more Partners but
I don't believe that makes them a bad
person right but you understand that the
way you phrased it makes every 25 year
old I understand you're a bad person no
I don't think so I of course you do not
stupid now come on peers Andrew you're
not stupid you know what that sounds
like to any 25 26 year old woman
completely and you're right so you have
maligned every 25 26 year old woman with
that statement and I'm simply asking you
to all those who are not of the type of
women that you've described it are you
sorry I don't want anybody to be
offended by anything I say I want to be
a positive force in the world I don't
want anybody to hear what I say and make
them feel bad about themselves I want
all people to live righteous and good
whether they're male or female
coming up more from Andrew Tate
so those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
you're the most honest man in the world
last week I'm a very honest man was that
true yeah I think I'm a very honest man
for those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had
of being president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question and I don't only believe
it I know it will happen
we will win you can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
because I like you as simple as that I
don't say that in public here
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist accident and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go up you know you can say
it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
I'm not gonna watch what I say sorry
because I don't think you do either
really I think that both of us I think
have the self-confidence to say you know
what stuff this nonsense uh yeah stuff
the fun police is saying well my great
friend used to say uh because I think
it's just so what it does it removes all
the fun out of life it makes life a very
joyless kind of experience isn't it I
don't know what's going on in the world
everybody's upset for something and no
matter what you say can please everybody
but for me the only person I'm
interested in pleasing is my wife and
I'm struggling with that most of the
time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife
she's always thinking I'm gonna get
canceled or something
[Music]
you posted openly about him six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
I'm holding him there's no moral view
from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one
on one
if you've ever been in love yeah how
many times uh plenty I believe in love
between men and women I'm a real love
you know yeah I believe how many times
would you say let's say 10 I mean I've
been in love and I certainly believe
that men and women when they work
together it's the most beautiful force
on the planet I believe in family I
believe in children I believe in why are
you single I'm not single well you're
not married so I mean well if I was
married the last thing I would do is
advertise it to the feral psychopath on
the internet so I'm not feral psyched
about well like you call me a friend
earlier it can be debated peers but the
point the point but the point I'm making
as a whole is that do you want to get
married no but this is we have to we
house all feed into each other peers I'm
talking about protecting a hard question
no but I'm talking about protecting and
providing for a woman I'm talking about
a man being responsible for her I
understand so of course I believe in men
and women of course I believe in love of
course I believe in marriage of course I
believe in families the idea that I
don't believe in the idea that I don't
believe in these things if you believed
it I asked you if you're going to get
married one day absolutely you'd like to
if I'm not married already I would I
will be married one day if I'm not well
you might be secretly married I could be
married correct why would you not tell
me either way why would I advertise to
the feral Psychopaths of the world who
have tried their very best to destroy me
for an opinion about my private life and
the things that are most sacred to me I
think if you said you were married
everyone would hate you I don't like
people hate me it's about me
understanding that I'm a hard target but
I am very very protective of the people
I care about right but you believe in
the concept of marriage completely
that's what we were talking about the
whole time what do you think we talked
about a man giving a woman away I
believe in marriage more than anybody I
believe in marriage and no please I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect a woman
and provide for her so he needs to make
sure that she's safe he needs a degree
of authority I have no problem with no
but no you but people do have a problem
with it and that's not sorry and that's
the word we're in now I'm over here sure
I don't have a problem with what you
just said here's where my problem comes
right there are a lot of clips of you
floating around on the internet as you
know one of them has you saying bang out
the machete boom in her face Ripper by
the neck shut up [ __ ] in another you
say slap slap grab choke shut up [ __ ]
sex
when people see those clips and here you
say those things agree well I don't
think that
it's not hard to misunderstand it it is
you might say that it's consensual other
people would say whether it's consensual
or not that's a very ugly way to talk
about women completely now that's
hitting them with machetes no watch the
whole video it's a girl coming at me
with a machete and me saying here slap
the machete out of her hand she's
attacking me so you don't understand
this is the exact point no people don't
watch them in full and this is actually
what's interesting and please don't
interrupt me on this point social media
has changed in Modern Times YouTube five
years ago was five six seven eight
minute long videos now we have Tick Tock
10 seconds 15 seconds 20 seconds YouTube
shorts Instagram stories now anything
you produce as long form is cut down to
very very short form they're interested
in clicks they're interested in
engagements they find the most they find
the most controversial Clips they can
and on purpose you benefited from all
that everybody benefits from social
media views yes do you yo was it the
Hustler what is it I had an online
school cool houses University right and
their whole job was to promote your
Clips Matthew rich and famous so you've
benefited from this system the one you
now profess to hate you benefited from I
never said I hate you clickbaited like
the best of them I never said I hated it
I'm saying what happened I don't hate it
I don't hate social media I think it's a
very powerful force I don't hate the
social media I'm saying that is I think
you can talk look you can talk to
girlfriends of yours
um maybe a secret wife I don't know or
two or two maybe you've got ten wise
that's your business I don't care right
my another thing is I don't get what you
do in private if you're consensual
between you and another woman you can do
what you like right it's your life I
believe in freedom and liberty it's when
you said in public it's the influence
that this kind of thing has on young men
I agree right and I speak to someone
with three sons right it's well by the
way they're intrigued by you they're
fascinated right you're you're a big
thing in that world of tick tock and so
on so they all are aware of you and what
you say so they're all looking And when
they see things like the machete thing I
get the context because I'm a 57 year
old guy who's been around the block a
bit and I can get what you said and
you're responding to a particular
scenario which you'd created where a
woman but it can be misunderstood I
understand so my point to you is given
that you know it can be misunderstood do
you regret saying things like this on
camera where it can be disseminated by
less intelligent young males who think
that is actually what they should be
doing to women and finally we get to the
point of the issue which is the point I
tried to make at the very beginning when
I made a video before I was famous they
got 500 views me being concerned that
one percent of people will misunderstand
it was not relevant we're not you start
getting five million views of video 50
million views of video one percent of
people misunderstanding doesn't change
no it doesn't but it becomes a much
larger problem and so with great Fame
that's true comes great responsibility
right so I agree would I now I'm famous
do I say things the same way as I did
back before I was famous absolutely not
right as neither would you or nearly any
other famous person on the planet once
you become famous you have to be a lot
more careful with how you say things I
understand so my logical follow-up to
that remains do you regret then saying
it the way you said it I can't live in
regret by saying something before I was
famous on a camera which barely anybody
watched and then I became famous
afterwards that would be a very asinine
way to view the world you can't live in
so you stand by all those I can't live
in regret because I didn't know I was
going to become the most famous man on
the planet you see one of the problems
that people have with you is that
they think you have a malevolent
influence on young people this was the
excuse that was put out by the big Tech
Excuse excuse being the key word well it
may be actually you know I I
intrinsically I have a problem with
censorship I don't think Donald Trump
should be banned from Twitter for
example because the Ayatollah of Iran
remains on Twitter and other social
media platforms and whatever I think of
you you're not the Ayatollah of Iran
right so there's cop there's a to me
there's got to be perspective here and I
don't understand the inconsistency by
what companies like Twitter how they
treat the the leader of Iran and someone
like you seems to me in a much more
Draconian of people like you yeah than
they are with people who perhaps should
not be allowed platforms
um but generally I don't really agree
with no platforming people yeah but I
think what's interesting talking to you
is it seems to me like you have gone on
a bit of a journey of self-awareness
about the impact of some of the stuff
you said in the past and you have said
you wouldn't say it again in the same
way now you may not want to express
regret for that but it shows me that the
very least you have evolved to somebody
who recognizes that these can be quite
damaging in the way that you said them
completely as a professional and as an
adult it would be stupid for me to sit
here and say that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet my words do not
have more impact than they did before
the final part of my exclusive interview
with Andrew Tate
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you seem
to be the most honest man in the world
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most reasons why am I not real but we're
not going to get into that let's finish
up the interview go ahead no go ahead go
ahead my question is this what message
do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had
but being president would you come back
a different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win you can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
but don't say that in public
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go up you know you can say
it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know you know I'm not going to watch
what I say sorry because I don't think
you do either really I think that both
of us I think have the self-confidence
to say you know what stuff this nonsense
uh yeah stuff the fun police is saying
well my great friend used to say uh
because I think it's just so what it
does it removes all the fun out of life
it makes life a very joyless kind of
experience isn't it I don't know what's
going on in the world everybody's upset
for something and no matter what you say
can please everybody but for me the only
person I'm interested in pleasing is new
wife and I'm struggling with that most
of the time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife
she's only thinking I'm gonna get
canceled or something
[Music]
you posted openly of having six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral view from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to a special edition of
Piers Morgan on censored Andrew Tate one
on one
you talk about people don't want to see
men dressed up in dressy I transgender
that's not exactly what I said what did
you say I said the reason I am so
popular and I'm so famous is that
there's a large contingent of men who
don't want to wear makeup who still want
to make money go to the gym be strong
drive a fast car be traditionally
masculine and don't want to be shamed
for that and they'd only be called toxic
for that that is the reason I'm so
massively famous that is what do you
think of transgender people that's
nothing to do with me I'm not
transgender and I don't understand the
issue like they do when they attacked me
they lump a whole bunch of things in
together they say misogynistic racist
transphobic they just put them all
together around a mixed race by the way
I don't know where they get these they
just get these buzzwords
I completely agree it's crazy and I've
had the same thing done to me okay and
I'm not calling you anything I'm asking
you what you personally believe you are
I it's not an issue I discuss what I do
discuss is that you support transgender
people I I support individual liberty
I'm a Libertarian so you support
transgender people sure what do you
believe about depression do you believe
depression is a real thing I believe
that feeling depressed is real I don't
believe depression as a clinical disease
is real now really correct you don't
believe people can be clearly depressed
I think PTSD is very real I've
unfortunately I have some friends who
suffer from that I know that feeling
depressed is real I believe that the
number one power you have against these
things are taking trying to take control
of your own mind and affecting your own
life I've lived a very difficult life
and I know people who have that the
things that made them feel better is
when they woke up and said you know what
I'm not going to allow this to damage me
anymore I'm going to take responsibility
I'm going to get up and I'm going to
fight this as hard as right and by the
way on that I agree so my favorite
speech is the Rocky Balboa okay so then
we agree no we didn't we don't agree
Pierce you don't hang on you've got to
let me sure interject when I don't agree
with you right where I don't agree with
you is that there's no such thing as
clinical depression there absolutely is
well it's a proven scientific medical
reality there's a different argument
about have we gone a bit too soft right
in schools and all the rest of it
absolutely yeah do I think some people
moan and whine too much about their lot
in life definitely okay are we a
victimhood society 100 okay is there
such a thing as clinical depression
absolutely so and my argument is that if
you actually bracket everybody who's not
Trinity depressed and doesn't have the
genuine medical condition then actually
if millions of people are deemed to have
depression the ones who really need the
help don't get it well that's my point
well that can that that I would agree
with you're right I think it's certainly
overused terms of things no I don't
Andrew You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
in it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts I'm never going to die
because I don't believe in it it's
ridiculous perhaps but if it allows me
to live a life where I feel happy
again this is that little area where you
lose me no I don't lose you because
somebody with your following so
thousands of people the thousands of
people who have emailed me saying my
doctor told me I was clinically
depressed and it's a disease that I have
got in my brain and I can't be fixed and
I started listening to you and I
realized that that's not the case and I
can fix my own life and you're the only
person who has ever helped me thousands
of people have emailed me that exact
email if you think you are
single-handedly curing people of
clinical depression you are living in
Cloud Cuckoo I am reading the emails of
people who I have cured of clinical
depression you're reading emails from
people who have believed you when you
say there isn't such a thing and they've
probably never been diagnosed illegal
depressed they just want to go along
with what Andrew dates says I don't
think so and I think your view of that
is that view is dangerous I I respect
that you think my view is dangerous and
I respect you have the right to view
that to think that I think that clinical
depression I actually agree do is
massively over diagnosed I've already
said that PTSD is a very real thing I've
already said I didn't so hang on okay
again you misquoted me I I did not say
clinical depression is massively over
diagnosed I said that people who claim
to be depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words there are
a lot of people who just have a bad day
yeah and declare I've got depression
yeah and I I say well have you been to a
doctor have you been clinically
diagnosed if you have and you have
clinical depression that's one thing but
if you haven't we could probably work on
some mental strength and resilience
skills with you but a clinically
depressed person has a an absolutely
proven medical condition that is beyond
their control not according to me and
many others my friend well look what do
you know about it honestly sure you're a
guy on the make he's done very well for
himself spouting stuff off much of which
I agree with as you've seen in the
interview uh but some of which is
ludicrous and that's one of them it's
not ludicrous it is it's not if you said
to me we're in a victim whose Society
has got to stop I'm with you okay at the
moment you try and deny clinical
depression I believe feeling depressed
is real I do not believe it's a disease
that you catch from the sky and you
cannot affect I believe that no matter
what happens I believe you have control
of your own mind and you can fight
against it fine good so we agree no we
don't yes we do no we don't fears are on
my side you're afraid of being canceled
along with me I said to you from the
start that's all I agree with a lot of
what you say completely so I thought I'm
taking you to task over the stuff I
don't agree with you sure and I'm just
not sure you understand why it's wrong
which is in itself quite revealing let
me talk to you about Alex let me talk
about Alex Jones right who I have a bit
of history with each other to get me
deported from the United States did he
yeah what is your view of Alex Jones I
think that Alex Jones is a Harvard
individual who very much like the Rabid
left deserves a chance to speak on his
points of view I think that the truth on
issues is usually somewhere in the
middle between two extremes and I think
do you think Sandy Hook was staged I
don't know anything about Sandy Hook
really you know he's just been sued by
the families for millions and millions I
have no idea you don't know anything
about it no so why would you support
someone in public you know nothing about
the most infamous when have I supported
him in public you have supported him in
public I don't know Sandy Hook I don't
know and you know what it was it was a
mass shooting of school children okay
but to sit and and he's actually no no
let's stop for a second please don't
interrupt me
that here's why you're I know why you're
good at your job first you interrupt
people a lot which is good it's a good
scale so you're right and then there you
go prove me right the timing is good
here's exactly what I did I only
interrupt people like you when you
either
refuse to answer the question or answer
a completely different one sure and I
want to remind you of what the question
was or when you misquote me back which
you've done repeatedly through the
interview where you say you see peers
you agree with me and the viewer who's
been watching will go no he didn't cool
no problem the other thing you do is you
try and set these traps like now so
you're saying what's the Trap you think
I'm sending you're saying that I agree
with every single point of view a man
has I literally didn't say that you're
saying well you support Alex Jones why
did you misquote me because you're
saying you support Alex Jones and you
said he you've been on his podcast and
he said this
I don't know what do you think about
exchange I don't know everything he said
what do you think of him I think I think
on his podcast he was cordial I think he
was professional on his podcast I've
also done podcasts with rabid leftists
and and people who openly hate me Alex
Jones said that Sandy Hook didn't happen
it was staged by actors okay this
compounded the appalling grief of the
families of those poor 20 children okay
who were gunned to Pieces by a lunatic
with an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle they
were already Greek stricken beyond
belief and this guy pulled petrol onto
that grief quite deliberately to make a
huge amount of money from his Infowars
fake news [ __ ] and as a result a lot
of the families have now sued him and
they've won and he's gonna have to pay
back tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars in Damages to these families and
quite right it won't do anything about
the pain he calls them some of them
actually have people turn up outside
their houses with guns because Alex
Jones had told them that these parents
were making it all up they were all
staged actors it was all run by the
government so I simply say to you now
I've told you that what is your view of
Alex Jones
I don't see why any of that has to do
with me I I it's very interesting I've
done the guys podcast I know him well he
was professional and courteous to me
when I meet somebody and they show me
respect I show them back respect that's
what I do as I dig with you you respect
him if somebody shows me respect and his
courteous to me I'm courteous fact
had a podcast would you go on it
sure you would great I've done a bunch
of podcast with people who are
advocating for things okay that I do not
agree with on every single level in fact
most of my podcasts are me disagreeing
with people so it's completely crazy
that you're trying to lump me in with
that that's cheap you are completely
misconstruing the point of what I'm
saying I think deliberately no no what
you're trying is a cheap trick and I'm
just making it clear I'm just curious
where you're like where your moral line
is it's a cheap trick is your moral life
I disagree with the points of view with
the majority of the people I do podcasts
with so it's a very cheap trick you're
trying here so people invent vile things
to make themselves rich off the back of
families of little kids who've been
blown to pieces with a machine gun
or a semi-automatic version of a machine
gun I think that is actually a line I
would I wouldn't cross I wouldn't be
happy to go on someone's podcast when
they've been responsible for doing that
it's not about political views or
differences of opinion over facts it's
about somebody deliberately inventing a
pack of lies to compound the grief of
families and I just I'm curious you
don't think you have any need to go down
any kind of moral quandary about people
like that before you continue to allow
them to use you for their own promotion
he didn't use me he didn't use me why
does he have you on the podcast because
we disagreed and discussed points like
we're doing with you right now did you
call him out on that are you using me we
didn't discuss that I'm not using I'm
giving you a platform most people aren't
giving you right now to show the world
who you really are fantastic so neither
of us are using each other I'm here on
your show I'm providing you with content
you're giving me a platform and nobody's
using each other it's mutual we don't
agree on a whole bunch of issues it's
fine and here we are I think we've had a
robust exchange do you identify as a
feminist I think that women and men and
are fantastic both of us are fantastic I
think women reproduce I think women need
to be respected protected provided for I
think that modern feminism is kind of
hard for me to even truly what do you
think it means what is feminism I think
that the idea of feminism is that men
and women are equal uh under the law and
do you believe that completely we have
to be treated completely yeah but we are
equal under the law wouldn't you agree
uh not really I think there are still
some issues in the world where I mean
certainly in workplace the gender pay
Gap remains uh they're not treated
equally in most cases women well that
can be discussed the gender pay Gap I
think that's already been discussed at
length I think that there's actually I
think women should go to work I think
women should work completely I do
believe that the most in my personal
view the most important and respectful
thing a woman can do is become a mother
I think that having children is a
beautiful thing chipmunk young men
though all aspire to be like you should
young men aspire to work very hard have
no criminal record become
multi-millionaires protect and provide
for the women close to them uh be
Sovereign so they can stand up and have
their own points of view in face of
cancellation be able to not be mentally
intimidated when they go on national TV
and there's traps set up for them yeah I
believe that confident strong men who
stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
a good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Nas twerking
talking on the devil on music videos
which our children are digesting you
have drillar is singing about stabbing
people to death in the middle of a knife
crime epidemic you have rabid uh
Psychopaths on whether the right or the
left announcing violence on the other
side I think if you're honest with
yourself that you can see why people
found a lot of the stuff you've said
problematic and misogynist and I think
you've recognized you wouldn't express
yourself in that way again because
you've understood that it's caused a lot
of harm and that's really really what I
wanted to get to today was an
acknowledgment by you that these things
clearly
were said in the wrong way created the
wrong impression if you didn't mean them
the way you intended them and can
therefore have a malevolent influence
when you have a huge following yeah when
you have a huge following you certainly
have to be a lot more careful about how
you get certain points across that's
absolutely a fact Andrew I appreciate
you coming all the way from Romania
thank you it's been an interesting
conversation and I thank you for having
it cheers man well that's it for me
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
[Music]
coming at 7 pm on Friday it's time for
plank of the week that's right it's when
we decide who has been the biggest plank
this week hasn't been a politician has
it been a member of the royal family or
possibly too has it been a football team
has it been an entire country we will
bring you the nominations I will bring
you the actual Plank and the prize is
right in front of me here don't forget
it's talk TV it's me Mike Graham and a
gorgeous panel of great guests it's all
here it's 7 P.M on Friday
foreign
to those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
you're the most honest man in the world
last week I'm a very honest man was that
true yeah I think I'm a very honest man
but for those who don't like you much
more honest than you actually really
yeah I'm pretty honest because I don't
think you're real right yeah I think I'm
a much more honest person in most ways
and most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message